Well, I'm honored to be
lighting bolt number one.
My name is Jonathan
Reuing-Scherer.
I teach statistics here at Yale.
I'm going to give
a quick discussion
about the way you use
video capture that's
built into Canvas.
So the first one I'm to talk
about is called Panopto.
I am not a Panopto
expert, nor do I
get paid by them to tell this.
So just ask, and I'll
tell you straight
up what my experience is.
If you go to Panopto's
website, what they'll tell you
that is that it's the
easiest way to manage,
live stream, record,
and share videos
across your organization.
And so the deal is it's
actually sort of part
hardware, part software,
part web-based interface.
And so there are a number
of classrooms around here
at Yale now that have basically
a permanent built-in camera.
And in addition to
the built-in camera,
there's this box,
which is basically
it's like a computer
with a big hard drive.
And the computer with
the big hard drive
is then tied in not
only to the camera,
but also to whatever is being
presented in the classroom.
So essentially, it's a
box that will capture
what's the camera,
whatever mic you're
wearing in the
classroom, and whatever
is going up on the screen.
It sort of automatically
captures all of those things.
Now, it's also
software that you don't
have to have on your computer--
I do on mine-- which
means you can also
use it to do a quick
video capture of yourself
just through your own camera.
So if you wanted to respond to
questions that students posed
online, or like, I got
the feeling in class
that you didn't get this today.
Here's three
minutes of response.
Very easy then to
upload onto Canvas.
And so it's also, then, a
web-based interface, which
is part of what I really like.
It's built-in to Canvas,
which is it's a great way
to grab the videos automatically
from those specialized
classrooms.
Or you can upload your own
videos that you make yourself.
I often use a program called
Camtasia, which is frankly,
a great video editing
software program
that I use for making
high quality content
videos that I use.
But Panopto is a great
way to organize those.
It's also a great way
just to watch the videos.
So it's also the interface
that students use
to experience video capture.
And say, it's also John
Harford-- if he's not here,
find him, because he's the
dude, walking right out there,
who's one of our
local Panopto experts.
And he's been awesome for
helping me integrate this.
So I used Panopto video
capture in three classes
over the last 12 months.
One of them is a huge class,
about 250 students, STAT 10x.
It's basically intro stats,
for mostly undergrads.
I also have, then,
a flipped version
of intro stats, which
is mostly grad students,
but a few undergrads.
This particular
class, actually, I
use that program can Camtasia
to make 50 high quality content
videos that students
watch before class.
And then, the class time is
used to run examples and answer
questions.
Then also, this
semester, I'm teaching
multivariate statistics.
This is an upper level, advanced
class for grad students.
There's about 110 of them.
And in this class,
it's also a live class.
So both the huge class, and
then, this multi-variate class
are classes I teach live.
I stand up, I give a lecture,
students show the usual time.
But the camera also pops on
automatically for each class.
And so there's a video capture
of the lecture as well.
So what I used in this STAT
10x class in multi-variate--
so I captured the videos,
they showed up automatically.
One of the things that's
great about the integration
of Panopto into Canvas is
that, literally, in week one,
I spent 20 minutes and
preprogrammed every time
that the camera needed
to show up or turn on
in a particular classroom.
And that was the last
I thought about it.
So otherwise, I just
show up in class.
I plug-in my laptop,
as I always do,
and the recording
happens automatically.
It streams live.
It's about 40-second
delay is what [INAUDIBLE].
But I hear they're trying
to get it down to 20, or so.
But it also, then,
automatically records it.
And so students, then, can go
on after the fact and watch
videos.
For my intro class,
Panopto is also
good as a video
organizational tool.
So as I said, I've produced
these content videos
for the flipped version.
But after a couple of
years, I was like, ah,
everyone who's in
the intro class
might as well have access
to those if they like them.
So it's also a great way
just to kind of organize
what the videos look like.
So this is more about
how do I tend to teach.
So my experience
with intro stats
is I'm trying to create
a multitude of ways
that people can learn--
sort of a stat smorgasbord.
And so any class I teach,
there's like 1,000 slides.
Big font.
They're sort of like that size.
So they can use those.
I release them in four
batches, so they're always
three weeks ahead, if
they want to read ahead.
They can come to class
where I'll lecture,
as I would usually.
And I'm happy to
answer their questions.
There's the video capture
of what happens live.
And then, for the
intro classes, there's
this kind of topic videos
So the deal is students can
decide to come to class if they
want, but they don't have to.
So if they'd rather just
stay home in their PJs
and watch the videos, that
is totally fine with me.
Or they can watch the PDF files.
Or they can do any
combination of those things.
And my experience is that
students do all of those.
Some of them have a
particular modality they like.
Many of them use more
than one, depending
on what's going on in their
lives and also the topic
that we're discussing.
So for those of you who
might be thinking like, gosh,
if I video capture my class,
no one will ever show up again.
So that was certainly--
you know, I thought,
what if I show up and there's
just me and the video camera?
[LAUGHTER]
So what I discovered is that,
in the large intro class,
only about 25% of
students decided
to exclusively watch the video.
So they just stayed
at home, and that
was the only way they wanted
to use the information.
It's been a larger percentage
in the multi-variate class.
So about 35% to 40% of students
decide to stay at home.
But it's interesting.
Even of the people
who show up in class--
every semester, I'll
say, quick show of hands.
Who's watched the
video at least once?
Now, students don't
like to raise their hand
under any circumstance.
And still, 95% of
hands go up and say,
we used it at least once.
Here are the reasons
that they talked about
for wanting to use the videos.
They had another class
at the same time.
They had to miss for
illness, et cetera.
Or they might just use the
video to review other topics.
So what I really want
to do now is just
sort of go show you
what this looks like.
So if you are in Canvas,
the way that this looks here
is that there's something
called Media Library here.
And so all of the
videos that I recorded,
they just show up like that.
And so to watch a
video then, this
is sort of what it actually
looks like, if you actually
are watching a video.
So students, then, if
they're watching video,
they get the screen
capture over here.
Or if they want to watch me--
I don't know who would want to--
but they can watch
me there, as well.
The audio was good, as long
as you have a good mic on,
as well.
If you're using Camtasia to
organize your videos, right
here under Create, you
can see the different ways
that you can make a
recording inside of Canvas.
So if you want to
prerecord, you just
go to the Schedule Recording.
But I've also used it to
upload pre-done videos.
Anyway, it's quick, smooth.
Now I'll shut up, so
you can ask questions.
[LAUGHTER]
What have you got?
Yes?
Another nice thing about this
is you can annotate time codes
to put in to, say, wake
up, pay attention here,
or this is the example I
did in class, or whatever.
And the students can also send
questions, based on time codes.
Yeah, which is cool.
And partly, because they
have these slides as well,
they can always just slide
along here and see what's
the slide number they're on.
So a lot of them will have a
hard copy in front of them,
even as they're watching
the videos to make notes on.
Other questions?
Yes?
You mentioned at the
beginning of the semester
you set it out to record.
Correct
So you [INAUDIBLE] the recording
yourself, using Panopto.
Right.
So how did it talk to the
box that you all used?
You can talk to John Harford.
He'll tell you all about it.
But literally, the way
it works, I'll show you.
If I were to go and schedule
a recording quickly here,
it says, I'm going to
go schedule a recording.
And they know where I teach,
so they've given me access
to a couple of rooms.
And so I just say, in this room,
at this time, on these days,
turn on.
OK.
That's how it works.
Other questions?
Yes?
Do you tell the
students explicitly
that you're going to be
filming your classes?
I do.
And do you find that has any
impact on their willingness
to ask you questions?
It has not.
The particular groups that I
teach, after a class or two,
they learn I'm pretty
low key, and they
ask questions no matter what.
And the camera certainly
isn't looking at them.
And in some ways,
the questions--
one thing I had to learn
was, the questions don't--
the mic doesn't pick them up.
So if they say something that
I'll be embarrassed for them,
I don't repeat what they said.
And no one will ever know.
[LAUGHTER]
But I tell them on day one, you
will be recorded in this class.
And you can use this
class however you want.
But I didn't hear
anybody saying,
I don't feel comfortable
being recorded here.
It hasn't come up.
Yes?
Have you noticed any difference
in the student performance
for that 25% or that 40%
who never come to class?
I don't have enough data to say
anything relevant about that.
But what I would say is,
the last, last thing--
I know I'm out of time--
I'm going to show you, is
that for any particular video,
you can go get all the stats
for that particular video.
And part of what's
interesting is
to see just the distribution
of who watched it when.
So for this one here, I'm going
to set it so it goes over the--
Are those the accounts?
Or do you have it
tied to their net ID?
Canvas automatically
links them in,
so it's sort of set
up automatically.
Anyway, what you can
do here is that, I can
actually-- it's not
[INAUDIBLE], but I
can see exactly who
watches the video when.
Now, the video went up here.
So these are the people who
got right on it and watched it.
These are the people
who waited until there
was a homework assignment
on that particular thing.
And these are the people
who wanted to review,
because they needed it
for their final project.
And if you look at
usage by individual,
you can see there are some
people who-- they're just
learners, they need extra time.
And so they'll watch
it two or three times.
Then, there's the
people who sit down,
and they watch it
once at a stretch.
But there's also
plenty of people who--
like they want 10
minutes at a time.
And so that's the
way they learn,
or that's the way that
they get interrupted.
And then, there are
people who sort of spot
check down here, like I
didn't get it in class,
so I'm going to come
back and just look
at that particular part later.
OK.
The end.
Good bye.
[LAUGHTER]